the biggest story all week what would be
the fate of Greece across you capitals
in here in Brussels citizens and even
some any peas took the street in
solidarity would Greece default or could
an eleventh-hour
agreement be hashed out so that the
country could claim with 7.2 billion
emergency loan multiple meetings all
week in Brussels on Wednesday MEP is
debated the issue it's not about
speaking a little bit of flow ventures
of picking a little bit of low wages
it's about changing the system can
Greece meet its creditors demands with
every hour counting you leaders are
hoping a deal can be reached something
money won't be a problem for Europe wide
investment at the mini plenary in
Brussels on Wednesday Amy please gave
their backing to Commission President
Yonkers 315 billion euro investment plan
with a few modifications the financing
structure has been made more democratic
and accountable and the Parliament has
also given itself a say in Lorenza fund
a Sunday a particular condition as for
my agenda quanta angular sand on europea
IKEA Sunday in Prague ooh we've cement a
positive cafes Repubblica care center
provided also on the rest of the plenary
money for redundant work is the European
globalization adjustment fund provides
at one-off payments to people laid off
work MEP is voted to approve Finland's
application of 1.3 million year is for
500 workers data protection reforms
enter the final hurdles with talks
between the three institutions on
Wednesday the aim is to protect citizens
better with EU wide legal protection but
strike a balance allowing companies to
access information more responsibly if
they don't find the 20 to 5 percent of
annual turnover companies in Europe have
to realize that this law if we pass it
will be one of the biggest subsidies to
European IT business which we ever did
because we minimize bureaucracy to an
absolute minimum we create a level
playing field
after so many deaths
by the European Union agency fundamental
rights to the migrants needs more legal
protection as they presented their
report before the civil liberties
committee the agency called for a
greater level of child protection and
rights of victims the committee was also
have any big earrings to choose a new
director for the fundamental rights
agency